today's episode of congratulations
brought to you by blue apron blue apron
is the number one fresh ingredient and
recipe delivery service in the country
for less than $10 per person per meal
blue apron delivers seasonal recipes
recipes along with the season along with
pre proportioned ingredients to make
delicious home-cooked meals check out
this week's menu and get your first
three meals free zero cost with free
shipping by going to blue apron home
slash Congrats
you will love how good it feels and
tastes to create incredible home-cooked
meals with blue apron so why would you
wait do it now that's blue apron dot-com
/ Congrats blue apron a better way to
cook my babies what's up this is
congratulations and I think this is
episode 20 spots 525 so this is the
first ever episode 25th episode of
congratulations you guys are getting it
before anybody else some people listen
to it right away as soon as it drops you
drop everything and you just download it
and yeah and you definitely listen to it
and you guys you guys are the truest
babies of them all so thanks for that
but then you know sometimes you have
work and you have other [ __ ] going on
life gets in the way and maybe listen to
congratulations the next day it's fine -
doesn't mean a not true baby it just
means you're not one of the truest
babies so that's so yeah so I was in
let's see where was I this week I was in
Austin and it was the most fun I ever
had in Austin actually I have my two
openers Mike and Mark and it was there
they're the least
Austin people of all time and I feel
like I fit in - Austin I love him more
than they do because I'm a little bit
hipper it more hipster my
my book my Irish friend Mark who opens
for me is not Austin because he's Irish
and he looks like he just woke up from a
bender in like the UK and his hair looks
like a [ __ ] bird of paradise and he's
got a Hitler mustache which is kind of
hipster but also he was wearing [ __ ]
board shorts everywhere because he
forgot shorts so not you know that's
like ultimate hipster but also not
hipster like he didn't mean to be so
it's not if he meant to be say hipster
but didn't so it's regular and so UK uh
even though he's [ __ ] Irish so UK
suck is what we call it suck and and
then I was with my other buddy Mike that
opens for me who is just basically the
most regular man you would see anywhere
and he is so [ __ ] a frat guy and
that's not Austin at all what's Austin
is people who wear long robe like shirts
and also boots with shorts and rose
tinted glasses or you know a guy with a
beard that's cut in fancy different ways
and also live music is everywhere which
also is weird when live music is
everywhere like we went down that 6th
Street area in Austin and it's basically
my hell on earth because everywhere you
walk by there's just live music playing
at every bar and just like you know I
don't know I guess they make money all
of these places but if you're gonna have
a place where like seven bars are have
one of the places or two of the places
have live music and also don't open the
[ __ ] in front of the bar so the whole
street has to hear live music because
guess what not in that bar if I want to
live in the live music I'll go in the
goddamn bar but don't open it up so when
I walk by swayed to loud got across the
goddamn street
alright it's offensive and also if
you're gonna have one bar open doing
that don't have seven bars open doing
that because then I'm not hearing any of
the songs I'm hearing all of the songs
and it sounds as a goddamn awful
you walk by it's like no no and then you
walk by another thing it's like we met
having the Beaman Beaman you walk by
another was like no no no no no no I
work by every bar girl I guess no no no
no no and when it sometimes I want to
run fast and I would go no no no I want
to do it fast
play the music in the bar don't open the
doors for everybody makes me blood bread
mad and yeah I don't but yeah if I want
to go listen to lab music I'll go in the
establishment to listen to live live
music yeah I got a question if you're
walking through a [ __ ] dry cleaners
if you're walking by a dry cleaners do
they [ __ ] shoot soapy water at you on
your shirt when you're walking by no
they don't because you didn't go in
because you don't want to get your
clothes clean because you're just
walking by so I don't want to hear the
[ __ ] live music if I'm now walking by
if I am walking by when I walk by
McDonald's do they shove [ __ ] burgers
in my mouth no they don't do that
anywhere when I walk dude here's the
deal if you're [ __ ] and walking by if
you're a bar that opens up a [ __ ]
live music shits okay and you're playing
live music for everybody then also open
up a mcdonald's and when people walk by
shove burgers in their goddamn mouth
okay same thing
100% same thing you [ __ ] my senses up
one of them's mayor senses and one of
those in my mouth senses dude don't do
it it's the same thing get sound proof
[ __ ] close the doors and have all the
[ __ ] bros in there by good gunk close
the door the gunk listen to music RAM
become real if I want to go in if I want
to leave free conch
but don't [ __ ] stall and don't be
stalling and make me listen to some [ __ ]
I don't want to listen to what says the
men who stare at goats so yeah so I I
did that in Austin and then I did a show
in Austin which is great I'm working on
some new material I mean I'm not really
where I'm working I'm working it in I
already know it you know I I do it at
the Comedy Store it's not like when I
play these theaters I'm [ __ ] working
this material
I mean I'm you know I guess a little bit
I am but I mean everybody's seen man on
fire which is great it's awesome but
like if you come to my show eyes
I asked Austin I think who see man on
fire everybody collapses like okay well
I'm not doing any of that material and
then so I you know so now I'm doing a
bunch of new stuff but and then I went
to Albuquerque man member what it before
I went to Albuquerque a few episodes
back on this podcast I said if you live
in Albuquerque who are you I still don't
know man
dude I was in downtown Albuquerque so
you know how sometimes when you go to
these downtown areas in these cities
that you don't know like it's all closed
because it's the downtown area like if
you go downtown LA and saw on Sunday
everything's closed or if you go
downtown Houston everything's closed
always it's just how it is I don't know
why it's [ __ ] weird but they're like
all like they all have them [ __ ] like
they don't even call they'll have like a
bunch of shops in a row and then it's
the district right like there's not just
one they'll be like oh yeah we were
gonna sell diamonds in this one shop oh
yeah we're gonna sell diamonds next door
- oh what's up diamonds next door - hey
you guys are selling diamonds let me get
up on this and this is just the diamond
district you know and then they'll be
like but yo check it out let's just
close all the time they're always closed
you want to go in and get diamonds you
got like call make an appointment with
some [ __ ] Russian guy but yeah so
Albuquerque has the downtown area but
it's also the area where you hang out so
everything is closed except for every
now and then there's like one thing
that's open and everybody there looks
like you know somebody else's cousin
everybody in Albuquerque looks like
somebody else's cousin if that makes
sense
I walked two [ __ ] five coffee shops
they were all closed
hey it's Saturday at 2:30 p.m. if you're
closed this Saturday at 2:30 p.m. when
do you open dude what do you want siesta
[ __ ] is this Italy we be right at the
back we're going to go eat the pasta no
I feel like they're siesta is they go do
math lose them listeners Albuquerque
dude
it's so hot it's also one of the only
places that's so hot outside and even
hotter inside whenever you go anywhere
you're like oh you got your conditioner
though right hey hey guys turn the air
conditioner on
hey somebody else's cousin turn aunt
turn the air conditioning on I feel like
if you walk up to anybody in a girl
[ __ ] and you say hey are you Frank's
cousin they'd just be like yeah uh-huh
here you Rick's cousin mm-hmm um yeah
it's a weird place man it's a weird
place and every [ __ ] thing there is
salba querque dude the artwork is so
Albuquerque like there's no other
artwork anywhere like this
it's like it's so [ __ ] I don't even
know what you would call it like it
makes me think of like Aztec [ __ ] that's
probably wrong but like every mural of
any person the person has a nose ring in
there knows any mural of any person they
have a [ __ ] nose ring if they have a
picture of Johnny Cash on their [ __ ]
side of their building Johnny Cash
they're like well we have to paint the
nose ring on that Johnny Cash disease
Albuquerque put a [ __ ] and give him a
who love up thing that he's jumping
through and a [ __ ] put a nose ring we
want rings they'll they're crazy about
circles there man they're [ __ ]
artwork is insane about circles salba
querque
so I did the venue I did the shop the
show and there were a bunch of people
there and it was a hundred and fifty
[ __ ] degrees in the place and I was
sweating my balls off but also wore
white shirts so it was okay if I wore a
gray shirt would it turned black shout
out to Cody
that was [ __ ] pink as [ __ ] dude
everyone in Albuquerque is like there's
a lot of white people which is very
weird because it's so sunny and I don't
know how everybody's suppe Ste white but
they're there it's a pasty white and
Cody was there a guy a [ __ ] pasty
white guy named Cody that was pinkish
[ __ ] like you know guys cuz I can't get
tan and they just go outside and they
get pinkish [ __ ] and they just look like
a dick like a [ __ ] they look like
balls they literally look like a hotdog
they look like [ __ ] Sammy Sosa does
now
you not I mean oh you Sammy Sosa
no you're just Cody cool get a tan
yeah dude looks like an uncooked hot dog
and he was an Air Force pilot and I
[ __ ] had some fun with him on the
show he is a good guy he's a good sport
so shout out to Cody and his Hawaiian
wife that was dark as [ __ ] he was so
white and his wife was dark as [ __ ] and
it was so funny
like like together they would have a
[ __ ] tan person so anyway that that's
what I did I did Albuquerque no school
couldn't wait to get the [ __ ] out
Albuquerque in the fence Albuquerque but
also yabba querque so you know what I'm
talking about because if you don't know
oh by the way if you're listening to
this and you're in Albuquerque wor'i'a
so that was they were fun though good
shows man I [ __ ] went to go to my I
went to I was oh oh I had to fly United
I had to fly United dude I got to United
and first of all I got to United and
they were like I checked in and I had to
do I had to fly like connecting to I
guess Albuquerque because that's what it
is yet because who the [ __ ] flying
director Albuquerque no matter where
you're from you can't fly direct
Albuquerque even the people that would
get on your second leg of the flight
directly to Albuquerque they have to go
somewhere else to they can't hear like
not allowed because it's Albuquerque oh
and by the way wait before I even talk
about the flying thing everybody in
Albuquerque wants to show you things in
Albuquerque that's how you know it ain't
that's how you know it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] my drivers like those mountains
over there are elevated 20 degrees
different just so you know you can hike
up there it takes about a few days and
people do it over here we got the the
the conglomeration of yadi duty I don't
if you want it and you can check these
out in 450 [ __ ] mom Potok over here
these the cloud this is what the clouds
come together and a lot of times it
rains and they used to call it the
mmm-hmm and instead what and so that's
that over here we have a mural that was
painted 40 years ago by and the mayor's
pissing and dude I swear to God you walk
into any where I walked into the hotel
and they were they were like these are
the original these four these are the
owners chess pieces that these are the
owners chess pieces that that the owner
a person collected from his travels all
over the world and I'm thinking oh [ __ ]
don't give [ __ ] and what they are in
there shelved in the original card
holders of where they used to and used
to hold the cards and then she should be
a picture next to the card holders a
picture of the card holders from
nineteen [ __ ] 12 or whatever and she
said in there there's the picture
there's a Hilton there's Hilton standing
in front of it and so if you want to see
it piss piss [ __ ] [ __ ] stop showing me
things give me to my goddamn room I felt
like I was gonna wake up in the middle
of the night and I was gonna wake up and
there's gonna be somebody next to me
dressed in a [ __ ] hotel uniform just
like this pillow is from 20 years ago if
you know who slept on this bed this
pillow let's close it [ __ ]
yeah so I got to you so United I got on
United and every now and then you have
to fly United even though hit severely
[ __ ] United we all know why how is it
still a business by the way I saw like
honestly I saw schoolboy q change it
who's a rapper changed name and he
tweeted that they put his dog on another
flight bro if I flew with my dogs first
of all here's the deal if I was a piece
of [ __ ] who flew with my dogs okay cuz I
got bottom line for you do not fly with
your dogs if you're somebody on an
airplane with a dog jump out no but jump
out when it's high up so it's all good
so you say you die you die and your dog
dies you take a parachute you land
safely wherever you want wherever you
want hopefully land in Albuquerque then
and know who you are
okay but dude if I now let me say that
something very sincerely now if I was a
piece of [ __ ] who flew with my dog okay
sincerely if I was a goddamn worthless
if I was a waste of human flesh that
decided to take my dog on an airplane
alright now if that's the kind of person
I was now there are people out there and
if you are if you're the kind of
worthless piece of dog [ __ ] that flies
with your dog okay now if I was that
person and I decided to take my dogs on
a plane and they put my dog on another
flight I I don't know how angry I would
be I mean how does that happen
first of all I don't even understand how
it works is you just carry your dog on
the flight right
unless wait a second now are you a piece
of [ __ ] who flies with a Great Dane you
got to store it or what what is it up in
the cockpit on the second chair dude
don't fly with any dogs okay don't even
barely fly with babies you're gonna fly
the baby my buddy flew with his big
newborn first flight ever bought
chocolates bought chocolates for
everybody on the flight didn't have to
but
shows everybody I'm sorry you got to
travel with a baguette you got to travel
your family I get it dude I fly all the
times all the time so far I fly all the
time
guess where my dogs go home they stay
there now I'm saying I don't mean to
ruffle feathers but it's cuz I'm not a
hot steaming pile of [ __ ] dude so but if
I did fly with my dogs and United put my
dogs on another flight dude rat a tat
tat rat a tat tat rat a tat tat dude I
mean come on man
schoolboy q change it um
nah but he's a good rapper I'm just
[ __ ] around I'm just [ __ ] around
but uh yeah so anyway so I got to onion
itíd and I was gonna fly to Albuquerque
from Austin and I get to the thing and
it's like so I you know I paid for the
first-class ticket or whatever on the
first leg I would you fly first Houston
it's like a [ __ ] 14 second flight
they're like there's like right here we
go to Houston alright we're gonna okay
seatbelts on all right now you can
unpack buckler seatbelts okay okay now
buck if seatbelts for for landing we're
about to land
oh that's how long the flight is you
could drive and and then we flew to but
the second leg of the [ __ ] thing
wasn't first class okay now I paid now
paid for first class now you could
imagine the things you can imagine how
mad I was already because I have to fly
United all right now you could imagine
how matter was when I got the second
ticket and it didn't say first class and
it said boarding group for now paid for
it
boarding group for what I can do is I
could ball up this ticket find the
United agent and just shove it up their
[ __ ] ripe [ __ ] I could do that okay
but I try to keep my cool I walk over to
a [ __ ] united person and I say excuse
me now now I now I assume look you work
for the [ __ ] airline you're gonna
know the answer to my question because
my question is gonna be a basic question
that you've definitely been asked before
because I'm not gonna say something that
hasn't been
before because I'm just a customer who's
trying to fly somewhere so I asked the
guy who I say hey man I paid for
first-class but I only got the first leg
first class and the second leg says I'm
not on first class and he says can I see
your ticket so I showed him the ticket
and then he goes like this
oh yeah you're not on first class on the
second leg and I said yeah I understand
you're saying that and so is the ticket
saying that however who pays for first
class for one leg of the [ __ ] trip
that makes zero sense at all so he says
he looks at me and he [ __ ] actually
asks me this and expects me to not knock
him out
he says do you have your receipt hey man
I looked at him like he had [ __ ] I
looked at him like his face was a
[ __ ] pig face like that's how
confused I was I looked at him like his
face was shelving units and I said I I
took a few beats cuz I thought he was
[ __ ] with me I thought maybe he knew
I was a stand-up and I said no I don't
have my receipt and I tried to say it
with enough venom in my voice because
Hey Dude what what was I supposed to
pull out what the [ __ ] was I supposed to
imagine if I was like oh yeah hold on
let me go into my bag and get my receipt
for this flight who the [ __ ] has a
receipt for a flight United hey dude I
should have [ __ ] looked at that guy
and asked him why his nose was facing my
nose hey dude why is your no I should
have said that dude I swear to God but I
didn't want to get an airport jail I
should have said hey man I should do you
have your receipt I should have said I
should have immediately said hey do you
have your receipt oh wait before I
answer that why is your nose facing my
nose because your nose should be facing
the same way and I should be behind you
[ __ ] you
up the ass for asking that question turn
round guy dude come on
where's your receipt he looked at me
seriously where's your receipt hey guy
has anybody shown you a [ __ ] receipt
for a flight ever even in the 80s
turn round turn round here
United terminal around here so I can
[ __ ] you up
P ass turn round here asking for seat
yeah oh my god dude so then I get to the
gate I'm like I just say not a mercy man
nevermind I'll [ __ ] figure it out
so I get to the gate and I'm like hey
ma'am now still on United I say hey
what's the deal here why do I not have a
first-class ticket when I get to Houston
to Albuquerque because I have one from
Austin to Houston and she says let me
let me pull it up for you
so nice she said okay cool so she says
oh it looks like there's a not first
class on not first class on the second
flight cuz it's gonna be a [ __ ] small
plane ok ok there you go there's the
answer there's the answer you [ __ ]
idiot there's the answer now look I know
it's a first world problem I get it dude
I sound like an [ __ ] I'm arguing
about first class but if you pay for the
[ __ ] you get this [ __ ] that's it I get
it
oh he's arguing about all he's
complaining oh so yeah ok you pay for
the [ __ ] you get the [ __ ] if I pay for a
burger and you give me [ __ ] half a
burger where's the rest of the burger if
I get if I get if I pay for
Berger and then a guy pays I think gives
me half of the burger and I say hey
where's my other half of the burger and
he says do you have your receipt I'll
[ __ ] all over the place oh wait till I
have to go and then [ __ ] all over the
place
sir why you still here hey drumming up
some [ __ ] sir you've been here for four
hours yeah I don't have to [ __ ] yet
that's why when I do I'll [ __ ] then I'll
leave come on dude by the way they spit
all over my shorts because I'm
passionate um yeah dude do you have your
receipt I measure the look on my face
for the people that know me and like are
kind of like true fans imagine the look
on my face when that guy said do you
have your receipt I should have said yo
you know you did to go so then I tweeted
about it I was like hey [ __ ] oh and
then they went to [ __ ] they were like
there's a delay on the flight there was
a delay on the flight and I was like
[ __ ] of course or I was gonna
miss my connection to Albuquerque and I
tweeted Oh what do you know [ __ ]
United [ __ ] up again don't fly United
and then they actually said never mind
there's not a delay I feel like they saw
my tweet I'm not that important but you
know what I mean
so yeah
and so I by the way dude here's another
thing about Austin I forgot to mention
when I started talking about Austin
here's something that just needs to stop
dude when you visit a place don't don't
I don't even know how to say this if
[ __ ] place I visit every single place
I visit and at least four times people
will say oh you know where you got to go
to eat and every time I go where and
they say some [ __ ] place are the
[ __ ] steak at Yacht it oh yeah all
you got to try the tacos that not oh
yeah did they got the best [ __ ]
French bistro gunk dude I'll go where
the [ __ ] I want I'll go to Quiznos
I'm not imagine that what's with the
fool everyone oh you got to try the fall
you're in Austin oh you're so lucky good
great food like I'm just gonna be eating
and eating all [ __ ] day long so I'm
squirting out [ __ ] taco me and my
[ __ ] throwing it up oh you got a try
I'm here for [ __ ] 14 hours you know
we got a try I'm gonna eat right we're
the closest thing is man I'm here for
work great just delete it all my notes
um hey you know where you got to eat you
know you got try yeah I'm gonna try the
[ __ ] hotel lobby food thanks
blue wait what do we got here one other
[ __ ] what am I doing here blue apron
is the number one fresh ingredient and
recipe delivery servers in the country
do you know that don't be left out blue
aprons mission is to make incredible
home cooking accessible to everyone and
they're doing it you want to be on board
or you cooed blue apron has established
partnerships with over 150 local farms
fisheries and ranchers across the United
States as a result seafood is soared
seafood is sourced sustainably under
standards developed in partnership with
the Monterey Bay Aquarium Seafood Watch
beef chicken and pork come from
responsibly raised animals that's good
come on guys blue apron ships the exact
amount of each ingredient required for
recipe so they are reducing food waste
as well so your guys are helping out if
you're doing this featured upcoming
meals seared chicken and creamy pasta
salad with summer squash and sweet
peppers so hard to say creamy shrimp
rolls with quick pickles and sweet
potato wedges it's hard to say fresh
basil fettuccine pasta with sweet corn
and cubanelle pepper it's hard to say
what's the word chili butter steaks with
parmesan potatoes and spinach and that
wasn't wasn't started with that one so
check this out this check out this
week's menu and get your first three
meals free with free shipping by going
to blue apron calm slash Congrats you'll
love how good it feels and taste - and
to create incredible home-cooked meals
with blue apron so why would you wait
that's blue apron calm / Congrats blue
apron better way to cook hey guys I got
a question for you you ever stop in
front of a newsstand with that is full
of beautiful magazine covers to pick up
the latest issue of bone Appetit or
wired or people but can't quite decide
which one you want to take home well now
you don't have to with the texture like
maybe you're at the airport or something
you know wherever you are a newsstand
with the texture app you get to access
your favorite magazines on your tablet
or phone it's easy it's like having a
newsstand right in your pocket only
really small the texture app has gone
beyond delivering just the magazine
itself they made it easy to find and
enjoy the articles you want to read with
daily recommendations exclusive
interactive features vide
and more can you get a video at a
newsstand and I can't texture mix
magazines easy and there are so many
great ones out there like you know I
like to read The Hollywood Reporter
because I'm so Hollywood I like to read
variety some Hollywood and sometimes I
like to read Vanity Fair to see what
everybody's wearing and looking all
high-concept
the list goes on they have them texture
is searchable so you can mark what you
like check out back issues view bonus
video contact content and they even
curate articles and magazines just for
you whoever you or whoever you're giving
texture to this year it's normally $9.99
a month and you get over 200 magazines
but if you sign up now texture comm /
congrats you get 14 day free trial so
why would you subscribe to a couple
magazines when you can have all of your
favorites on your smartphone or tablet
all the time for way less right now
texture is offering my listeners a 14
day free charl when you go to texture
calm / Congrats
14 days to try texture for free when you
go to texture calm / congrats texture
calm / congrats ads are over I'm
sweating like a [ __ ] dude I got
some pillow my mom made me buy on my
back and it's just sweaty mama's boy
yeah so how about this jay-z albums you
guys hear this jay-z album is it good
you guys like it I listen to it it's got
some [ __ ] good songs on it I feel
like the guy could come out with
anything though he's like Beyonce he's
the male Beyonce come out with anything
people to be like it's amazing people
would just be like it's fire as many
people say Beyonce you [ __ ] you go
yay
you go yonce not yeah you [ __ ] you go
Yonsei he'll be he'll be it'll be like
it's fire I just like a jay-z's like
starting to turn into [ __ ] what's his
name
Simon and Garfunkel Paul Simon is that
his name we're just like talking it now
and saying things and you're like wait
whoa is this a song though like it'd
just be like yeah I bought some art
you're like oh yeah I bought art I
bought some art you know be like boom
boom
boom boom boom boom yeah pour some arch
Tim boom boom boom boom boom gossipy
million dollars boom boom boom boom boom
I bought art from Jews he mentions Jews
a little too much in his [ __ ] album
you know why Jews have a lot of money
boom boom doom doom doom doom doom
because they save a lot of money - doom
doom doom doom
spuddy their culture doom doom doom the
poor art from them stoom boom boom boom
boom choose love art doom songs called
Jews love art no no the song will be
called like hello and you be like oh
it's just one about and then all of a
sudden like whoa whoa these [ __ ]
crappy juicer by and ha oh why did you
have all the art when I was some art the
dum dum boom boom what some art for 1
million to do then a year later this Jew
told me it was 2 million I'm into it you
know what Jews have all the money like
alright man what the [ __ ] happened with
you and a Jew a douche Jews have all the
buildings doom doom try to buy a
building from a Jew but the [ __ ] Jew
took the building and then roofied me
and then [ __ ] me in the butt boom boom
boom
I mean the song with where he mentions
Jew the Jews like that is called the
story of OJ nothing to do with it
this is the story of OJ anyway what's up
with all the Jews don't students tomb
why they got all the building institute
don't tomb like what I lost my mind
did you put a roof you much
[ __ ] me up the ass so now no matter what
the song is a talk about Jews don't
don't don't do because I got some deep
issues about choose to kind of hungry
for salad maybe I can order one from a
Jew go down to the cafe pass and Jews
while I'm going and then order salad sit
near some Jews don't do boom do you guys
have matzo salad them don't do what the
Jews eat around here I wanted them to
test the story of OJ what like come on
do it
holy [ __ ] I'm sweating so hard the more
I laughed a more sweating I get that's
[ __ ] weird dude I can't wait to give
my art to my children oh [ __ ]
I wish jay-z heard me to do that you
know that'll never happen
but I wish it did [ __ ] man well it's
like none of it is like it's just like I
don't know the way jay-z does is just
like he's talking to us like Paul Simon
like Paul Simon would be like yeah I
walked down to the market today and
bought a piece of chocolate and then I
ain't the tongue there and then I went
home prima Green but what happy note did
you pass Jews they don't know stoon I
want Paul Simon and Jay Z to do a
[ __ ] song Paul Simon is like went to
a baseball game went to a baseball game
whoo how many Jewish players on a team
know ah so funny so [ __ ] funny
goddamn I'm sweaty as [ __ ] oh man
I mean dripping it's the [ __ ] air on
hold on
[ __ ] it all right guys look it's time
for most the most [ __ ] up Instagram
post of the week and we got one right
here some of you guys send them to me
and I appreciate that because I can't be
looking for the most [ __ ] up Instagram
post of the week but this one was I
believe this one was sent to me I saved
them now I'm not gonna say the name and
this time I'm gonna read the comment
first and then describe what's in the
picture okay so here it is from this
this this woman I guess yeah she's a
woman for sure main thought exclamation
point the individual himself is a
fallacy oh dude
first of all that's where I stopped
reading the first time and I was like oh
[ __ ] and I looked a few other buzzwords
throughout the whole thing is a long one
but I looked through the oh I was like
ah [ __ ] it's gonna be amazing
alright cuz the words [ __ ] you
guessed it is the word is the word
cosmically in it you guessed it is the
word unity in it you guessed it is a
word misconceptions in it you guessed it
belief you guessed it is the word
fallacy in it again you [ __ ] guessed
it do they say cosmic love you [ __ ]
guessed it dude these are all real words
that are in this egoism you guessed it
altruism you guessed it all these words
are in the same post this is why this is
the most [ __ ] up Instagram post of the
week now here we go main thought
exclamation point the individual himself
is a fallacy everything which happens in
us is in itself something else which we
do not know the individual in quotes is
merely a sum of conscious feelings that
our conscious feelings that I sorry I
it's getting hard I can't get past that
without shedding my self-conscious
feelings and judgments and
misconceptions a belief a piece of the
true-life system or many pieces thought
together and spun together
quote unity that doesn't hold together
this is what she's saying
we are buds on a single tree now we're
human but that's what they said - what
do we know about what can become of us
from the interests of the tree oh you
hear the student but we have a
consciousness as though we would and not
sorry we would and should be everything
a fantasy of quote I and all quote not I
stop feeling oneself as this fantastic
ego learn gradually to discard the
supposed individual discover the
fallacies of the ego recognize egoism as
fallacy the opposite is not to be
understood as altruism the [ __ ] this
would be love of other supposed
individuals no get beyond quote myself
and quote yourself experience
cosmically freakin cosmic love bro
alright now I don't know what that means
now I'm willing to understand maybe I'm
a [ __ ] idiot and maybe that means
something that's incredible because
there's a hundred and nine comments but
here's the deal the photo is of the back
of a girl and she's naked okay okay and
you knew it was gonna be of that she's
King naked with GOG with a thong on and
she's talking about cosmic love now if
you're naked and you got a picture of
your thong the caption should be about
your [ __ ]
it should be about your booty not cosmic
love not how we are buds on a single
tree not only buds you should be talking
about her your dingleberries cuz it's a
shot of your [ __ ]
dude what is this world coming to
now maybe I'm an idiot but these
comments dude
these fart look at these guys trying to
[ __ ] her you're a stunner and an
intellectual the world we know
boundaries are what thought as education
to fit in careers but heating to the
wise and their dark sayings is boundless
where we're from what's our purpose
where we go after flesh and return to do
it all over again and again hey man go
to a strip club get a hooker the [ __ ] is
this idiot saying some guy writes
sweetheart besos some guy writes this
photography is truly sexy hey get a
hooker some guy writes some guy just
writes oily ass hey dude and it's
[ __ ] oh wow some guy writes
incredible incredible physique perfect
and siga
signalling the caption some guy just
writes send me something oh here's the
comment some guy wrote lmao this [ __ ]
Chris D'Elia that's how that's what sent
it to me oh my god dude
some guy writes you should smile more on
a post of her ass how do you know she's
not saying some guy writes beauty but
Sephora n-- dude
get a hooker guys this guy had it going
says the girl putting up a thirst trap
pics really some of you IG girls realm
need to stop it realm I think you meant
to say real real I mean yeah get over
your ego don't [ __ ] post about your
ego don't this and that hey here's a
picture of my ass in a g-string
[ __ ] you CUDA gonna get a [ __ ] tattoo
that says he koude on your ass I don't
know man super weird
alright I'm gonna now I'm going to the
tags babies because you guys tagged me
all up this this this week
congratulations pot tag seeing who's
gonna game the system was not alright
here we go
mmm latest uh have you ever been [ __ ] on
by a penguin no that's a stupid [ __ ]
thing this guy's trying to be funny I
think Jesse benbrook at Jesse Ben bro
okay cool
Jesse Ben Burke uh maybe he did get [ __ ]
on by a penguin because he said tagged
zoo trips but whatever but I saw a guy
get [ __ ] by a bird and it went in his
mouth and I was like game over
[ __ ] are Kelly was saying about
how according to BuzzFeed report parents
are accusing our Kelly for allegedly
holding their daughters in a cult you
know like hey man the [ __ ] you holding
women against their will in abusive cult
I mean you're not if you're holding
against their will it's not a cult man
you're gonna [ __ ] be in a cult you
join it because you want that's how my
cult is you're joining cuz you want my
god
oh wow somebody's got a [ __ ] I'm
gonna retweet this Joey bats at state
football absolutely change it [ __ ]
state football in the meantime somebody
[ __ ] like some state football team is
like trying to get your [ __ ] handle
and you're just Joey bats like a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
you CUDA he says and there's a [ __ ]
license plate on an Audi that says CUDA
oh one nice
[Music]
there's a nut here's another one from
Kelly Robinson at K underscore Robinson
1988 at Chris Lea thoughts on people who
bite the middle of their popsicle first
like goddamn psychopath all right look I
like die don't that doesn't bother me
but I like that it bothers you that's
the kind of thing that we need to move
this [ __ ] cult forward these kinds of
thoughts because we need rules for our
cult
do you understand we need that to happen
like you know and the rules are
constantly adapting and changing like
for instance there were no shorts for a
while but now there are as long as
they're [ __ ] nice jean shorts that's
how it came from I'm I'm the Prophet and
that's how it came from above but
thoughts on people who bite the middle
of their popsicle first like goddamn
sacrifice now here's something I would
say to that person Kelly if she's a baby
in my cult you know [ __ ] our Kelly by
the way that [ __ ] is wack I'm talking
about the real [ __ ] dude if it bothers
her so much and she thinks that if you
do that you Kuta then what you got to do
is present a case to the [ __ ] to an
elder and then he presents it to me
but I like that I like that when you
have a passionate thing about that like
if someone thinks if someone has seen
that a few times like I don't think that
this is something that happens too much
but you know maybe she lives in a place
where popsicles are [ __ ] like always
getting bitten in the middle first and
if you are then you present the case and
we say look you can't do that or you're
a cootie you're ousted from the [ __ ]
cult
so good job Kelly Robinson bringing that
to me I'm not sure if it's a [ __ ]
thing here but somebody sent me a thing
with relationshipgoals what do you think
about these girls for a relationship
Matt sent it at Emma PPO nine I mean
change it make a little easier obviously
but relationship goals picture where a
guy is holding a gun naming it and a
girl is in front of him holding a gun
aiming at both their pants are down and
he's [ __ ] her doggy style if that's a
relationship goals I hope you slip and
shoot each other in the head by mistake
go free cars free conch but don't anyway
oh yeah here's one Andy at a howler
three see here's another one you come to
my cult you come to my thing bring it to
opinion what is your opinion on grown
men who wear athletic shorts under their
pants or jeans yeah well you seven if
you do that you seven or you Blake
Griffin about to play all right if not
then you know don't do don't do but
you're gonna wear [ __ ] athletic
shorts under your jeans first of all you
freeze it cuz you're gonna sweat and you
have swamp ass so much but that's so
insane to do that actually I've seen
people do that and they go it goes all
frump DUP under their belly with red
[ __ ] shorts and their [ __ ]
buttoning they're like who what lunatic
would do that this is a great thing for
the cult like nah you get rid of the
athletic shorts period how about okay
you gotta wear I mean unless you're
working out even if you're just chilling
like get out of here dude putting pay
under pants ever pants under pants is
ridiculous underwear is the only
acceptable thing me on DS and it's
because [ __ ] you're gonna sweat
probably maybe or you know if you get a
little bit of dribbles of piss on your
[ __ ] underwear you don't want to get
it on your jeans or corduroys or khakis
or cargo pants we're winding down and
I'd like to thank all my babies here and
I would like to say that the merchandise
is going quick man go on my website
Chris D'Elia calm and go get a freakin
shirt or a shirt about or a shirt for
the podcast you can support it or you
got other things that you know like
store shirts instead of shirts and all
that [ __ ]
I get the tired Eagle shirt but there's
two new shirts this the Freak conch and
another one what is it the
congratulations it says support the
podcast rate and review the tweet rate
and review the podcasts on app on iTunes
please stitcher google play tweet me at
the hashtag congratulations pod at
hashtag or not I was right the hashtag
congratulations pod and then I got some
upcoming shows let me read them off here
should have done this enough I would
forget to do this [ __ ] in the beginning
and by the way also you got to watch the
special man on fire if you haven't
watched man on fire yet if you haven't
watched man on fire yet very cool that
if you have but if you haven't get on
that when you can it's streaming on
Netflix so you can watch it whenever and
the other ones there too incorrigible
still those are about three years ago I
got someone's coming at some shows
coming up Montreal Nashville Hollywood
California Salt Lake City Utah Phoenix
Arizona Tempe Arizona spoke can
Charlotte vine California Melbourne
Sydney and I'm trying to work out some
other dates and try to work out some
other dates of me
and in Australia considering I'm gonna
be over there but we'll see if it works
out or not has to work with that's
working scheduling and all that and
venue availability you guys are the best
Jorma babies thanks a lot and we'll see
you soon person [ __ ] artwork for 1
million weekly there was a million in a
little bit more